my name welcome back to fire fire my
head is oh wait climb over all right
let's investigate this little pudle Who
ah [__] me why are they come hey hey hey
hey who you kill your friend did you
even realize holy [__] where are they
come a [__] me there's so many oh
they're blocked too I don't like that
hey heyy hey hey hey he hey hey hey hey
yeah hey fatty oh nice hit bro I know
you try I know you love me I know you
care I block your [__] cuz your face is
scary oh oh that was a nice one
bro but you can't hit me because I have
boot in your butt and your face and
triple boot oh you
m you can't even hit the [__] penis
that's how much you suck now face the
snap watch
your that's what I'm talking about the
watch
up a bit tired right now a lot of action
going on I better hurry though maybe I
can find some dead birds on the way have
you seen any dead birds look at the Moon
W ah [__]
me not him please at
least oh [__]
we are we are disc screwed that's is how
it is we're going in there is this a
puzzle apples I Apple's not helping me
right now all right maybe if I burn
the thing
well what about over here no it's
definitely
here why would I burn it all right punch
it no they're glued I can't jump I can
only use my brain right now and it's not
serving me well well God damn it maybe
maybe just maybe I should have gone up
here why yes I'm an idiot all right
there even [__] things there to show
it the way doesn't matter you never stop
firing do you oh it's a little offit I
thought
can't hello is this an ice cream shot
what oh the M14 holy [__] [__] better
recognize I don't want the M14 I have
the firepl it's better I'm just kidding
I want the
M14 all right [__] come here boom
boom boom got to get that boom boom boom
got to get that
boom oh [__] me why I waste all the ammo
all
right bro let our battle begin I start
with a boat oh nice hit oh ow ow ow stop
please it hurt it hurts it hurts
I'm stop being
mean I don't like when they're oh nice
one nice one one more and I'm
dead you suck bro oh oh [__]
me
no why did I waste so much [__] all
right good thing I quick saved call me
the quick save Master there it is
because I am a noob all right there we
go I'm not a noob I'm a Le hexer bro all
right let's do it more gentle this time
ladies one at a time please ohom oh that
hurt oh that hurt oh right in your penis
right in your nipple right in your a
[__] all right he should be pretty
tanked down let's just face him come
here brother I show you a stick up your
alley oh hey which one do you want how
about the ram watch
out that's what I'm talking about the
watcha you don't [__] with the watcha
PA that's right ah no not more don't H
me
hello apples do
something someone following
me oh that's fat he fell he fell through
the fly he's too fat
W all right Patty we got to battle
you're so good at battling not
fair block
it block it I blocked it [__] oh I
forget the boot that's why boot Bo
that's right you mad you don't have
boots that's right stay down [__] all
right I waited for you [__] piece of
[__] I love you [__]
do I don't whoa oh no it's GNA
crash [__] I doing so well so well yeah
you have no idea you don't even know
okay you maybe watched me but otherwise
you didn't know that
much come on I don't even know which one
I maybe the processing
center it's it 22nd today yes
okay this
it oh there was a health station here
why thank you I'll take both of them
that's okay
good where the [__] am I
now what is
this what H did I take another route
what are you wa stay down [__] you too
you all stay on the FL ground oh no it's
a
n [__] n [__] hey I'm fighting a
ninja here ah [__]
me well that's right ninja you don't
have a wooden stick I have two of them
well you two actually come on you can't
hit me from there ninja [__] come
closely come here in he spikes here
stupid [__] ow
I got Zerg I got Zerg like
a all right let's fight the ninja again
I guess he's the final boss now we
fought him before though I had this
stupid stick I wish had a better weapon
or some [__] oh yeah I forgot the health
packs [__] come on P they [__] Focus
man I'm trying it's not that easy you
know but I don't care what they say I
will will block your
[__] they try to all right
n let our final battle begin don't run
away from me all right he's going to
stay down stay down make sure you're
dead Bo power I SP oh you felt the boat
power didn't you [__] you [__] you [__]
all of you [__] my life I'm out of here
no no no no back off back off back off
I'm backing up backing up backing up
backing up he's [__] behind me isn't
he
I'm [__] you don't sneak up on me
n that was close that was close stay
under that Bo to the boat
boot oh can I take them I took a
stick I love you boot I love you too
P you're the best P I know but you are
the best now you're the best now I'm the
best what and you're the best okay okay
yes okay just
stop all right
n enough of this all a fat this is come
on man in sake of fighting can we just
get along ow boot to the face oh what
you going to do what you going to do
when they boot on you stop it I'm not
I'm not even [__] there I'm so sick
of it stucking I didn't even mean to
boot that
[__] oh I block your [__] Bro a
[__] [__]
you
stay down
[__] what
[Applause]
[Music]
no the [__] try hard time it is it is
on it is on
[Music]
I got this I got this no no problem no
problem no
problem I got this
boot eat
and you don't even know what you're
doing hey your brother's coming
doublehead oh you your brother you
stupid [__] oh that's right tank
him oh [__] you
this is so
difficult all right all right all right
all right I got this not a pro I was
born doing this all right let's kite him
until his brother comes and then I'll
let his [__] brother [__] him stupid
[__] stupid [__] smack that all on
the floor smack that give me some more
Smack That
stay there stay there stay there I dare
you nice hit bro nice H hey how the hell
do you hit me from there shouldn't even
[__] be possible all right your
brother's here take
him all right swing your balls I'll just
[__]
chill how does that even hit me oh
that's fight each
other fight each other do it do it I'm
not I'm not here I'm not here I'm not
here I'm I'm a pole shote
activate [__] finish him finish him
finish him finishing boat do
it nice boat nice
boat that was a [__] mess quick save
quick save on that [__] two of them it's
like what the hell do you think I
am all right all right we got
this someone's sneaking up on me oh no
it's a n oh
[__] okay I hate the N hey
tractor a they got guns now one shot am
I dead I don't even how my Taser all
right bro don't shoot me don't shoot
me
I'm I'm all
right
like I'm going to no we're doing
it don't sneak up on me you [__]
n is he after me or what how am I oh
wait that's
a sub I'll see you
next
I get a feeling that I
never I a good
feeling the the walk the